[Aplausos]
meu crescimento foi prejudicado por um
conceito de beleza errado
não sei se você também foi criada para
acreditar nessa tremenda piada só sei
que chegaram em mim muito cedo com
imagens que me causaram medo mais do que
medo me causaram frustração porque eu
não tinha controle sobre essa questão me
ensinaram que cabelo crespo era sem
jeito arrancaram minha negritude dentro
do peito fizeram minha cabeça entrar em
pane
mas hoje eu quero mais é que se dane
essa sociedade não conhece o meu valor
agora eu já conheço enxerga além da cor
essa foi a primeira rima que eu escrevi
o hip hop é o meu grande amor
o hip hop me ajudou a ser quem eu sou
mas vamos começar do começo eu sou uma
pessoa com muitos sonhos são meus sonhos
que me ajudam a caminhar
eu preciso de novos sonhos pra continua
quando criança eu sonho em ser bailarina
hoje eu sei que eu não danço bem eu
sonhei também ser escritora entre outras
coisas algumas coisas eu realizei outras
eram sonhos criança que se saíram como
neva através do tempo
a questão com os meus sonhos é que eles
geralmente são maiores do que eu e um
desses sonhos cresceu e ganhou
proporções que eu nem sequer podia
imaginar
eu queria ver o mundo aí você se
pergunta mas qual é o problema em sonhar
sonhar é uma coisa boa é verdade mas é
que quando a gente nasce da ponte pra lá
como é o meu caso
menina negra nascida e criada na
periferia de são paulo
as pessoas fazem questão de dizer que
sonhar não é pra você e que você deveria
como se conformar com aquilo que está ao
seu alcance mas eu nunca fui muito bom e
me conformar meu primeiro grande sonho
foi aprender inglês é uma língua que
para mim parecia el ficar algo mágico
na época eu não tinha muito recurso
então eu estudei sozinha eu traduzia a
letra de música eu fazia qualquer coisa
para conquistar esse meu sonho na
adolescência
deus me deu um aliado e alguém que seria
o companheiro para os meus sonhos
quando eu conheci o hip hop
foi como se todas as respostas tivessem
chegado
eu ainda lembro de mim
calça bege e rosa e os meus óculos
sentada na calçada ouvindo espaço rep e
sonhando em como seriam os carros low
riders lá nos estados unidos que
balançavam ao som do rap no alto falante
mas mais do que a capacidade de sonhar
o hip hop me deu também algo muito
precioso foi o hip hop quem me ajudou a
estrapolar limites e sonhar cada vez
mais alto foi o hip hop quem me ajudou a
sair da caixa que havia sido desenhada
para mim eu costumo dizer que o hip hop
é o meu grande amor é o meu amor mais
antigo pois é ele que dura mais tempo
para sair da caixa o hip hop me ensinou
quem eu sou mulher negra criada em uma
família de negros de pele clara que não
se identificavam como tal foi através do
hip hop que eu entendi o que é o racismo
como ele me afetava como e afetava a
minha família e aqueles que estavam ao
meu redor
isso mudou a minha vida completamente
uma das pessoas que se tornou ídolo pra
mim disse em um discurso que ele também
tinha um sonho o sonho dele era viver em
um mundo onde seus filhos não fossem
julgados pela cor da sua pele
naquele momento o sonho de martin luther
king e de tantos outros que lutaram
contra o racismo se tornou também o meu
sonho foi o hip hop também quem ensinou
o que é a diáspora que nós somos um povo
negro ao redor do mundo
quando eu vou para os estados unidos a
primeira vez eu consigo realizar um dos
meus sonhos eu finalmente desde os
carros low rider se balançavam ao som do
rap no alto falante e é verdade eles
balanço mas mais do que isso eu consigo
perceber as semelhanças entre os jovens
negros do brasil e dos estados unidos e
construir pontes
quando chega a hora de escrever
é esse conteúdo que eu vou utilizar para
falar sobre o racismo sobre como eles
tem nos afetado sobre como nós
continuamos sendo excluídos em qualquer
lugar do mundo e como eles continuam nos
matando aos montes em toda de aspa
quando eu volto pra lá pra fazer meu
doutorado
qual vai ser o tema da minha pesquisa é
lógico que só poderia ser o meu
companheiro de sonhos mas a essa altura
deve estar se perguntando mas o hip hop
não é aquele movimento onde os manos e
as meninas andam de calças largas e boné
nós somos isso também mas mais do que
isso o hip hop é um movimento cultural
composto por cinco elementos que
representam todas as formas de arte
o dj ou diz que jovem representa a
música instrumental oms
o mestre de cerimônia é o cantor de rap
e junto com o dj eles formam o elemento
musical
o boy oab girl são os dançarinos de
break e eles representam a dança o
grafite representa as artes plásticas e
o quinto elemento talvez o elemento mais
importante do hip hop é o
autoconhecimento a importância do
autoconhecimento pode ser percebida na
própria definição da palavra rep que em
inglês significa ritmo e poesia mas que
em português nós e ressignificando anos
para dizer que pode significar também a
revolução através de palavras e foi esse
quinto elemento o elemento filosófico
por trás do hip hop que me despertou no
passado e que é a base do meu trabalho
acadêmico hoje quando chega a hora de
escrever a minha tese
eu decido falar de outros jovens que
assim como eu encontraram no hip hop uma
motivação para lutar
para transformar para buscar para
alcançar sonhos eu decido falar de
outros jovens que encontraram no hip hop
um companheiro para os seus sonhos
mas mais do que isso eu decido devolver
ao hip hop aquilo que ele me deu de mais
precioso a capacidade de sonhar porque
compartilha essa história com vocês hoje
eu conto a minha trajetória pra vocês
primeiro porque eu preciso sempre que
possível fazer declarações de amor ao
hip hop
segundo porque eu tenho que dizer pra
outros jovens que assim como eu nasceram
da ponte pra lá que sonhar é possível e
que eles podem construir pontes e
conquistar o mundo
terceiro porque eu acredito que
sonhadores precisam ouvir histórias de
realização de sonho pra sonhar cada vez
mais alto e você qual tem sido o seu
sonho com grande você tem se permitido
sonhar e 4 porque o hip hop me permite
expressar em rimas aquilo que nem sempre
pode ser dita
sentada na calçada ou uma canção que
fala de problemas referentes à nação
problemas que não me eram desconhecidos
questões que me abalavam e mexeu muito
comigo falava da pobreza na periferia
falava do descaso com a grande maioria
mencionava bairros que estavam ao redor
de us e vielas que há de mal a pior
me identifiquei com aquela descrição
parecia que aquilo era sobre a minha
situação e isso despertou minha
curiosidade me fez perceber qual era a
verdade verdade que abre os olhos do
alienado que faz manos e minas correrem
lado a lado
cada vez que eu encontrava um dos
elementos aumentava a minha sede de
conhecimento me fez entender o que é ser
negra por aqui que se eu queria mudança
eu teria que agir me mostrou as
ferramentas do sistema e tudo que estava
por trás daquela cena que não adiantava
nada sentar e chorar que essa descoberta
era motivo para lutar mas que nessa luta
eu não estava sozinha que tinha muitos
outros com a visão igual à minha
quer ser uma jornada de muitos heróis
que se levantavam contra o all boys
heróis que lutavam para quebrar as
correntes deixando livre o corpo a alma
ea mente me apresentou a líderes
mundiais que deram suas vidas pela paz
falava da diáspora em outras nações que
naqueles navios tinham muitos porões
porões lotados de homens histórias que
era necessário resgatar sua memória isso
norteou minha caminhada me fez entender
qual seria a jornada
comecei a lutar por igualdade estudei
lutei busquei pra mudar minha realidade
mas não posso esquecer o que ficou para
tais nomes fatos memórias que não voltam
mais vidas que se cruzaram pelas ruas da
cidade que juntos desenharam uma nova
mentalidade todos motivados pela mesma
dor unidos pelo som pela paz pela cor
minha vida não seria a mesma sem o nosso
encontro tudo mudou a partir daquele
ponto sem a sua ajuda não estaria aqui
muito obrigada por você existir e é por
essas e outras que eu preciso dizer hip
hop
eu devo muito a você obrigada
[Aplausos]